hey everyone it's nurse Sarah with
registered nurse rn.com and in this
video I want to demonstrate how to
provide CAF care and Perry care to a
female patient so let's get started so
I've washed my hands and I've done clean
gloves first I'll remove the catheter
from its securement device now some
guidelines may suggest doing calf care
before perineal care While others may
suggest doing the opposite therefore you
always want to check your facilities
protocol for the proper sequence for
this demonstration I'll perform Perry
care first so what I'm going to do is I
want to start with the cleanest areas
and work to the dirtiest area so we're
going to start on those inner thighs and
we're going to go from top to bottom and
then another thing you want to remember
is that whenever you are providing peri
care with a patient who has a catheter
you don't want to be tugging and pulling
on this catheter and sometimes you know
it's inevitable you're going to brush up
against the catheter that is okay as
long as you're not tugging and pulling
on it so we have a washcloth that has
soap and water on it we are going to
fold it in half
and we're going to create those four
leaves so each side will wipe another
side without contaminating so we're
going to warn the patient we're going to
touch them and clean the inner thighs so
we're going to go from top to bottom and
we're going to pull that leaf back going
to the side closest to us that thigh top
to bottom pull that leaf back go into
the other side top to bottom pull that
leaf back go the other side top to
bottom and we have washed that area now
we need to rinse now we have a new cloth
with just water on it because we're
going to rinse so again fold it in half
create your leaves hold it here here's
your leaves warn the patient you're
going to be touching them and you're
going to rinse again where you started
so rinse from top to bottom that inner
thigh
pull back rinse that other inner thigh
top to bottom
pull back
and then you have your last Leaf top to
bottom discard this and then get a dry
towel and then it's the same concept
with the dry towel we're just you can
really just blot the area with your Leaf
pull back blot the area
pull back
blot the area
and then bought this area and then
discard so now we have a brand new cloth
with soap and water we've four leafed it
so more in the patient you're going to
be spreading the labia we're
concentrating on the labia majora so
we're going to the labia furthest away
we're going to go from top to bottom on
that labia
pull that leaf back go to the other
labia top to bottom
pull that back go the other side
top to bottom
pull that leaf back top to bottom then
discard get a new rag now I have a new
cloth with just water and we're going to
rinse the areas we just cleaned so warn
the patient touching them going to go
from top to bottom with that leaf pull
back
top to bottom pull back
top to bottom
pull back top to bottom now that area is
rinsed so now we're going to dry and
then it's the same concept with the dry
towel from Top
to bottom
other side top to bottom
top to bottom and
top to bottom and discard that and then
lastly what we're going to do is we're
going to clean labia minora and the
urinary meatus so I've got a clean cloth
with soap and water on it and I've
leafed it we're going to start with the
labia furthest away so warn the patient
that you're going to be spreading the
labia minora now the thing here with
this mannequin the tissues are very
stiff and a real person they are very
easy to spread and you can really get in
there you can get around the urinary
meatus and get each fold of the labia
here the mannequin does not want to
cooperate so you will get the idea the
big thing is what you want to do is you
want to go from top to bottom pull your
Leaf back getting as close to that
urinary meatus as you can and those
folds from top to bottom
pull that back
top to bottom
pull that back and you have your last
Leaf top to bottom and again making sure
you're not putting any tension on this
catheter line then we're going to rinse
the same way with a new cloth with water
so again warn the patient you're
spreading the labia we're going from top
to bottom to rinse puller Leaf back
top it's a bottom to rinse pull our Leaf
back top to bottom to rinse pull our
Leaf back top to bottom puller Leaf back
and get discard this so now we have a
brand new towel it's dry and we're going
to blot those areas dry in that same
exact sequence so
hop to bottom pull back top to bottom
pull back you really want to make sure
you get the areas dry because germs love
to grow in wet places so we don't want
any water left behind and then top to
bottom discard then gently turn the
patient onto their side to provide care
to their backside making sure that you
put no tension on that catheter we got a
new cloth that has soap and water on it
and we're going to fold it into our
leaves so we're going to start on the
cheek that's furthest away and we're
going to go from front to back because
we don't want to go from Back to Front
because we would spread germs and then
we're going to go to the cheek that's
closest to us go from front to back pull
back a new Leaf so we're on our third
leaf and then now we're going to go over
the anus so we're going to go from front
to back cleaning that area pull back
that leaf on our last leaf and front to
back then we're going to discard this
and get a cloth with water now we're
going to rinse with our new cloth in the
same motion so front to back
front to back
front to back discard and get a dry one
we have our dry cloth and again we're
going to go in the same sequence and Pat
it dry so
front to back padding dry
and then our last leaf
and discard this after you've done that
just make sure your patient is okay on
their side and then quickly you want to
doff your gloves and perform hand
hygiene and Dawn a new pair then once
you have your new clean gloves on you're
going to assist the patient back into a
line position make them comfortable and
then you're going to perform calf care
the reason you want to clean the
catheter is because this gets germs on
it and as germs get on the catheter they
can Ascend migrate up into the bladder
and cause a caudi which is a urinary
tract infection we don't want that for
our patient so first what we're going to
do is we're going to get a washcloth
with soap and water on it and fold it in
half create your leaves very first thing
what we want to do is we want to tell
the patient we're going to be spreading
the labia specifically we're going to be
spreading the labia minora because we're
going to clean this catheter line and
what we want to clean first is the first
two inches where that catheter is going
into the urinary meat this so at that
medial Junction and we're going to be
careful not to put tension on the line
so we want to clean that first so we've
warned the patient we're going to spread
the labia we're going to take the first
leaf and we're going to go
in a circular motion like so then we're
going to pull back this leaf and we're
going to just repeat that again cleaning
those first two inches around that area
now we're going to pull back we're going
to go with our third Leaf but this time
what we're going to do is we're going to
hold this catheter line about right here
and we're going to go down in a circular
motion and clean the rest of this tubing
all the way to the bifurcation
so we're holding it steady so we're not
putting tension on it and we're just
going down that line all the way to the
bifurcation
then we're going to pull back that leaf
on our fourth leaf and we're going to
repeat this again
we're applying soap and water to all of
this and now what we're going to do is
discard this get a new cloth and rinse
now we have a new cloth with just water
on it again we're going to fold it in
half creating those four leaves so now
we're going to rinse those same places
that we clean with the soap and water so
again warn the patient that you're going
to be spreading the labia we're going to
go in there we're rinsing the first one
to two inches of that catheter line at
that medial Junction
so once here then we're going to pull
back to our second leaf and just repeat
that
then we're on our third leaf and we're
going to hold this here so we're not
putting tension on the line we're going
to just go down and rinse that line all
the way to the bifurcation
and then we're going to pull back for
our last Leaf hold again and then rinse
all the way down to bifurcation then
we're going to discard this and get a
dry cloth now we have a dry cloth again
we are just going to fold that exactly
like how we did before we created our
Four Leaves and we're going to go and
dry in the same way that we washed and
rinsed so again when the patient
spreading the labia
we're into
dry there's first two inches pull back
that leaf do our second leaf
then we are going to proceed with drying
the line so we are going to hold that
part and just go down that catheter all
the way to the bifurcation
do your last leaf
all the way down to the bifurcation and
then discard now let's Golf our gloves
perform hand hygiene and place the Foley
catheter back into its securement device
and before you place the catheter back
in its securement device assess the
device make sure it's clean and it's
still working and that it doesn't need
to be replaced with a new one and check
the date of when the last securement
device was placed onto the skin with
these stat lock devices you usually want
to replace them every seven days
whatever your facility's protocol is